you're all familiar with life hacks
right life hacks those creative
solutions to common problems things like
using a comb to hold a nail in place you
don't hit your finger simple stuff like
that it's all over the internet well
anyway Andy has put together some new
life hacks and he wants to tell us all
about them isn't that right Andy yeah I
thought it'd be a new feature and stuff
okay
we're always looking for new stuff now I
haven't seen these yet so let's look at
them together in a piece called Andy's
life hats
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Andy Richter if your in-laws are
stopping by and you don't get along with
them try this right before they come
drink four beers the visit will fly by
and you won't resent them as much like
that got a tennis appointment here's a
tip when you're in the waiting room
drink four beers you'll be extra numb
and pain free when he works on your
choppers like that does your neighbor's
dog keep you up half the night with this
barking drink four beer
pretty soon you'll be drowsy and
snoozing the night away like that you
know we all have that kitchen drawer
that accumulates odds and ends before
you organize it drink four beers and
then Andy Andy you'll be like it's so
it's messy but so what I mean
I know it's in there who gives a [ __ ]
okay Andy
and II mean Who am I trying to impress
it's my house Andy stop those are your
life hacks yeah I mean I've got
literally thousands of them I mean I
guess you could call me a hack a haul
and Andy every single one of your life
packs involves drinking four beers oh
yeah it's weird huh no it's not weird
it's dangerous it's you're responsible
frankly Andy it's stupid maybe maybe
you're right I mean can I could I just
do one more
okay one more sure do you hate your boss
because he's a judge three four beers
[Applause]
his back off I'm still three beers away
from liking it
we have an amazing show tonight from the
new movie cop car Kevin Bacon
okay thank you any I love you too from
former White House chief of staff author
of the new book the quiet man John H
Sununu is here he and Maggie Naya is
here
[Applause]
we'll take a Oh God will take a break
we'll be right back with a lot more
Ginny hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography